that's the insane thing is that I don't
know if it's I don't know if Japan is
the only country that's like this but
it's cheaper to eat out there it is to
cook your own food it's the same thing
inside I think I really like that I can
okay because at least in Australia like
Jesus Christ no one goes to restaurants
because it's like I don't want to gamble
if this $25 pasta is gonna be good or
not like I'm sorry I'm like I'm not that
rich yeah I'd rather just go to the
supermarket just cook a five-dollar pass
I'm here in Japan and to get like a
single I'm a single line I paid two
dollars two dollars for a single [ __ ]
line what's that spying I wish no I
don't think anyone's mentioned that on
YouTube people don't tell you how
expensive it is to cook here yeah yeah I
don't know if this is just like I may be
in America it's different not we're not
for America and I know the prices for
fresh food in America is like ridiculous
yeah but in the UK I don't know about
our failure in the UK like buying
ingredients is so incredibly cheap Oh
nobody eating out is not so much you do
for the food it's more of like an
experience with your friends no no I for
an event
right it's a luxury yes don't do it
because like you know you you have the
money it's like you do it for a reason
and then you like if you speak to some
of the UK and I know that if you say
like you eat out every day in the UK
everyone's like yeah because like in the
UK
you don't eat out alone Yeah right it's
very rare to do something like eating
out alone in here
more people eat alone and then cook you
and then cook you know because it's just
more convenient and it's cheaper as well
cuz my god vegetables here meats are
okay but vegetables are so expensive and
I don't know why wake up and in the
biggest offender in my mind limes
terrible peppers you know normal bell
peppers yeah in the UK I distantly
remember in like Aldi or even like Tesco
let's go it's like one pound 29 right
for a pack of three bell peppers right
that's like what $1 60 yeah in Japan for
like a single bell pepper which comes
with its own packaging it's like 180 yen
if you want to have three Bell per box
so that's that's to last six dollars for
three Bell Pat are you [ __ ] can we
talk about the biggest defender though
which is fruits oh roots like a they're
good that good good good good
but Jesus talked about overpriced yeah
you know they're like Japan has this
like weird obsession when it comes to
first words okay
oh it's from this girl massage it's like
oh it's from this specific Prefecture
that specializes in that for therefore
if you want to buy an apple from like
all Modi Prefecture which is like known
for the apples it's like you know a
regular Apple like I don't know about
the UK but at least in Australia it's
like if you want like a freshly ground
you don't [ __ ] know where I come from
good quality like you know homegrown
apple right the most you'd pays maybe
like a balk yeah I've never paid more
than 50 cents for an apple no I know I
think I'd be shocked if I paid more than
where is he
if you want like a specialized branded
Apple which is like the only kind of
apples they have here for some reason
yes like oh yeah 600 yen please there's
no cheap brand here it's like it's
everywhere every brand has a certain
story and it's like that it's like you
know when you have Asian grandparents or
something everything they feed you has
health benefits they feed you like this
vegetable this fruit like oh this is
really good for eggs this is it's not
proven but it's like a wives tale all
right